sie ist sympathisch bodenständig trotz
ihres erfolgs ihr leben und die rollen
gehören zusammen
manchmal frage ich mich ob das kino mein
schicksal beeinflusst oder ob man
schicksal in die filme hineinspielt gold
farahani ist die vielversprechendste
iranische schauspielerin ihrer
generation
egal ob in venedig cannes oder berlin
ihre filme liefen schon auf allen großen
festivals
in der comic roman verfilmung polio
grünen verzaubert sie uns mit ihrer
schönheit im drama about elly
überwältigt sie uns mit einer breiten
palette an emotionen ein durchbruch für
das neue iranische kino dessen
beliebtestes gesicht sie war als eine
der ganz wenigen iranischen
schauspielerinnen spielt es in einem
hollywoodfilm im thriller body of lies
behauptet sie sich neben superstar
dicaprio eine verhängnisvolle nebenrolle
die gemeinsamkeit zwischen mir und den
meisten meiner rollen ist wir wollen
individuen seien dafür bezahlst du aber
einen preis
bestimmte gesellschaften dulden keine
individuen
in ihrem aktuellen film the patients ton
stein der geduld spielt sie eine frau in
kabul
die sich verzweifelt um ihren verletzten
mann kümmert die trotz krieg und
zerstören einen bemerkenswerten weg
findet dem leben zu trotzen
ich wurde in der zeit des iran irak
krieges geboren meiner frühesten
kindheitserinnerungen sind am krieg
geknüpft ein kind weiß eigentlich nicht
was tod bedeutet aber das erste was man
in der kriegszone lernt ist das deine
mutter und ein vater plötzlich sterben
können
fasziniert beobachten mehr gold schiffte
farahani wie sie ihr leben riskiert um
sich um ihren mann zu kümmern
erst auf den zweiten blick verstehen wir
die umsorgen des gatten als pure
überlebensstrategie
schließlich ist das leben einer witwe
dort wertlos
gold schiffte farahani reißt uns mit
wenn sie frauen aus dem orient darstellt
kennt sie deren gemütslage nur allzu gut
ihr scheint die rolle auf den leib
geschrieben ausgesucht dafür hat sie der
exil afghanen karimi er hat seinen mit
dem prix goncourt ausgezeichneten roman
selber verfilmt sie hat in ihrer heimat
große dramen erlebt dadurch hat sie die
fähigkeit präzise gefühle für jede szene
zu finden
was mich an ihr so fasziniert ist ihre
ganz besondere schönheit diese
unschuldige schönheit hinter der sich
gleichzeitig eine starke persönlichkeit
verbirgt deutsche stefan stammt aus
einer schauspielerfamilie
schon als fünfjährige lernt sie klavier
spielen schafft später die
aufnahmeprüfungen ans konservatorium die
kriegserfahrungen als kind das leben in
einem totalitären system
all das hat die 29-jährige geprägt
die entscheidung ihre heimat zu
verlassen ist aber wohl die wichtigste
ihres lebens nach den dreharbeiten in
hollywood wird sie zu hause monate lang
von den behörden drangsaliert
bis vor gericht gezerrt mit der
anschuldigung das ansehen des landes
beschmutzt zu haben plötzlich merkte ich
dass der iran das schönste land ist in
dem ich leben könnte
aber ich habe realisiert dass ich dort
meine karriere auf sand bauen und
jederzeit irgendjemand kommen könnte und
diese zerstören kann ich meine das ist
doch wahnsinn
also habe ich mich entschieden dieses
schicksal zu ändern
ihr schicksal in die eigene hand zu
nehmen
das entspricht golshifteh farahani und
den meisten ihre figuren das pariser
exil für sie ein hoher preis für uns ist
es ein geschenk wenn hier steht sie erst
am anfang einer großen karriere